foreign
good afternoon I'm Adrian Dix I'm BC's
minister of Health my right is Dr Bonnie
Henry BC's provincial Health officer
this is our respiratory season update
today I'm honored to be here we're
honored to be here on the territory of
the LA quangan speaking people of the
sanghis and the esquimal First Nations
it's Public Health Week where we
recognize all of the people doing
extraordinary work in very challenging
times in public health and in public
health the week is my particular honor
to introduce Dr Bonnie Henry our
provincial Health office
thank you very much and good afternoon
so I'm very pleased today that we're
able to present some data and give you a
summary and an update of where we are in
the respiratory season this year
so to start with
um this is a slide that is familiar to
most people I think it goes back one
year to April of last year and it I'm
going to walk through the epidemiology
that we're seeing right now of covet
influenza and RSV
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and some of the other respiratory
infections that we've been seeing and
we're going to talk about changes to the
restrictions that are currently in place
in our Healthcare settings and some of
the surveillance tools that we're
continuing to have so as you know for
the past year the kova 19 that we've
been seeing has all been variants of
Omicron and what we have seen is a
leveling off and a decreasing of
hospitalizations and the new daily
hospitalizations are presented here and
as you know these are anybody who is in
hospital with a positive covet test so
we know that a good proportion of these
people have incidental findings and the
reason for hospitalization is not
necessarily related to their covid and
in addition we present all cause
mortality within 30 days of a positive
test and the dotted line on the bottom
is when we update so it's not as timely
as the information we get about daily
deaths but it is more the underlying
cause of death that we get from Vital
Statistics and that has shown quite
consistently over the past year that
about 40 percent on average of people
who die with a positive covet test that
that their death is directly related or
indirectly related to covet 19.
and as we've seen throughout this
pandemic people who are older
particularly people over age 80 and
people who are immune compromised
whether the vaccine doesn't work as well
are more likely to be hospitalized and
have a higher rate of hospitalizations
so they are the people who are most
severely affected and we've seen that
consistently and we can see from our
data here that it is people over age 80
in particular who are more likely to to
be hospitalized and that's of course why
we are focusing on this group of people
for the spring booster which is really
starting in Earnest this week
months after people received their last
vaccine
and as we say as I mentioned our 30-day
all-cause mortality has been coming down
over the last little while and we've
been following this and consistently as
I said The more accurate underlying
cause of deaths from Vital Statistics
confirms about 40 percent of people who
die primarily older people are from or
related to covid
other things that we've been following
along the way have been the impact of
vaccinations and so this is age
standardized rates of covet
hospitalizations Critical Care
Admissions and deaths starting in
September of 2022 so just over the last
period of time and what we can see
across the board is that the highest
risk continues to be in people who do
not have any vaccine and that's across
all age groups so for age matched people
despite having we know there's a lot of
people who've had infections with covet
at various times and including
re-infections the best protection you
have continues to be from vaccination
and from vaccination in some people in
some cases having infections as well
I want to talk a little bit about
Wastewater because if we've been in a
transition and it has been I've heard
from many people that it has the current
figures that we have up on our bccdc
website show when the new testing
protocols that we have were put in place
but it is somewhat confusing because
there is it looks like there is an
increase in detections when what we've
done at the bccdc is go back and re-test
all of the archived Wastewater samples
from the past year so that our future
reports will all now be on the same
Baseline using these more accurate more
precise tests and what we've learned
from that is what we've been trying to
say but now we can put it up on the
website in a much more understandable
fashion is that the covid levels are the
sarsko V2 the virus levels in Wastewater
in March in particular we're stable and
decreasing at all Sites across the
province so this is the the ones that
we've had in place for quite a long time
so since the beginning of the pandemic
in Metro Vancouver and as we can see
there was a leveling off and and some
oscillation over time which is something
that we expect to see in Wastewater and
I would just note that for those who are
looking at the details of this the load
per capacity axis is higher so it's the
numbers higher on the on the x-axis with
the new tests because these new tests
pick up more of the virus but the number
is not as important as the trends that
we're seeing over time so what this
gives us a better example of is what
we're what we're seeing over time and
that's the important part that we look
at the fact that we're able to pick up
more of the virus enables us to do more
whole genome sequencing and that's also
really important part of our
surveillance it allows us to to
determine what strains or what variants
of the the in this case mostly Omicron
are circulating where around the
province and and of course really
interestingly and and exciting for us is
that we now have some good data from
Fall of last year in Island Health in
Interior Health and again in all of
those communities where we're doing
Wastewater surveillance we're seeing
similar patterns
smaller numbers and they're more
flexible or the more variation because
these are smaller communities but in all
cases we're seeing a nice decrease over
time
I do want to talk a little bit about
markers of immunity in the community and
we do that by understanding things the
zero prevalence so how many people have
antibodies in their blood from either
infection or from vaccination or from
combinations of those and this slide is
an updated up until the end of December
2022 and it really shows us that we have
a lot of immunity or markers of immunity
in our community across the board in
young people it's more likely to be a
combination of infections and
vaccination and in older people
particularly people of 70 and 80 and
older it shows that the vaccines have
been working really well the proportion
of people in that age group who have
immunity from infection is much less
so we have a very high level of
antibodies from the combination as well
of infection and vaccination and that's
really important that hybrid immunity
gives us a lot of buffers so it protects
not only us as individuals but the fact
that we have a level of immunity in our
community means those people who don't
respond as well to vaccines or whose
immunity wanes are protected because the
rest of us are protected too and we see
in younger people there's many
combinations of immunity that we see
right now so combinations of vaccination
and infection people may have two doses
and an infection or several infections
or three doses or four and so all of
that together tells us that we have
quite robust immunity in our community
and that's been borne out with what we
see in the in the hospitalization and
the serious illness as well where those
have stayed down or level
so this past fall and winter we also
experienced a very significant for the
first time in a couple of years
influenza and RSV season added on to
covet and in particular we had increases
in the fall as you will recall
um particularly in children so this
shows
um the reason are they uh the projectory
trajectory of what we've been seeing of
uh since the fall in the Pediatric
population and so it is a mixture but we
have seen for the first time in a couple
of years that influenza which is the
purple in this really peaked quite early
earlier than we usually see it in young
people and we also at the same time
started to see RSV increasing if we look
to where we are now in March and later
in February we're seeing other viruses
that are still causing respiratory
infections particularly what we call
enteroviruses and rhinoviruses and
adenoviruses so those are ones that
cause typical cold like some symptoms
and I think when many people I know
anyway are still seeing lots of costs
and colds in kids and in older people
and most of them right now are not being
caused as we say by um by influenza we
did see a little blip in influenza B in
late March and early April but influenza
is now leveling off and going away
so if we look at
um the the what we saw in breaking it
down by different viruses particularly
focusing on influenza RSV and cyrusco B2
this is what we saw in the overall BC
population quite a peak of influenza in
November so earlier than we usually saw
it and we did a press briefing we were
talking about that impacting adults as
well as children and we had some severe
illness in children that was related to
influenza and we can see quite a
dramatic decrease in a large part of
that is because we had such a great
uptake of flu vaccine in the fall that
helped us moderate and temper that
increase in in influenza we also saw RSV
increase particularly in children and
you can see that this is focusing on the
data we have from Lower Mainland so
Vancouver Richmond and North Shore but
it reflects what's happened in the rest
of the province as well where RSV and
influenza were both at their Peak around
the same time and a little bit later for
RSV but it's also decreased and in the
midst of that for the older populations
we see that SARS is relatively our
sarsko V2 is relatively steady and for
children it was low and steady as well
if I put this slide in just to give you
a sense of where we are with what we saw
this past respiratory season with
influenza and RSV compared to historical
averages this is 10-year averages from
previous Seasons so the green line shows
the last few months that we've been
through and we can see we had a much
earlier peak of influenza but that it
came down quite rapidly and a large part
of that was because of people being
vaccinated and we saw a little bit of a
blip with uh influenza B but it's hardly
noticeable in the figure here and then
in RSV was the same thing we saw an
earlier and sharper peak of RSV but it
also has settled down
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
the surveillance products that we have
in the bccdc and there's some dates up
here that people can have
um just to reiterate that the
surveillance that we've been doing is
key to understanding all of our
respiratory viruses and how they're
behaving and we will continue to do this
but as we usually do once flu season is
settling down and the the typical
respiratory season is settling down we
we go to a longer interval so the
respiratory data web page on the vccdc
website will be updated today and we'll
have the new Wastewater on there and it
will be updated then bi-weekly until the
end of May and then we'll have our end
of season report for covet we are going
to continue because we're still in that
transition period of the pandemic and
there's still some uncertainty about
where we're going to be so you will get
bi-weekly reports of covid on the bccdc
dashboard through the summer and into
next year
but we'll go to monthly in in may just
because things are not changing that
quickly
um the other thing I wanted to put in
and I'll go through this pretty quickly
we have along with these changes we've
revised the algorithm that goes into the
reporting of infections hospitalizations
and new daily deaths and to make sure we
talked about this last fall but in the
past the way that the algorithms were
working it included the first infection
and we now know that many people have
had re-infections so we've revised the
algorithm to include re-infections after
a period of 30 days and the team went
back and re-analyzed the data since we
made the initial changes in April of
2022 and you can see that there really
is very little difference in the the
numbers and the rates over time but this
is a more sustainable way to approach it
and it includes which will be important
for the future being able to include
re-infections in these
so there'll be footnotes about how this
is all done for those who who need those
in the on the website
so what does this all mean
we said we would keep many of the
restrictions that we've had in place in
our health care settings in particular
over this season and we're now at the
point where surveillance will continue
and we will continue to monitor what's
happening and the the vaccine
requirements for health care workers
will continue but we're at a point now
where we can change some of the
restrictions in healthcare settings in
particular lifting the visitor proof of
vaccine and vaccine requirements and the
rapid antigen test requirements before
entering a long-term care assisted
living home and some other health care
facilities
um and removing the mandatory Universal
mask wearing in all Healthcare settings
so what is important to note is while
the mandatory masking orders are being
lifted masking remains a very important
tool in the healthcare setting and
healthcare workers will still wear masks
based on their risk assessment so what
patient they're seeing what the symptoms
are what the person has where the
setting they're in and you might be
asked to wear a mask particularly if you
have symptoms yourself and are going
into a health care setting for care or
are in certain settings within the
healthcare facility so there are some
units some parts of of our hospitals for
example that require masking and have
for a long time things like people who
have units that look after people who
are severely immune compromised or burn
units
um as well we have a couple of
healthcare settings so Healthcare
facilities and and long-term care homes
that are experiencing outbreaks and they
will continue to have outbreak measures
in place which may include limiting
um visitors and masking as well
especially though as we transition over
the next few days you may be asked to
wear a mask as people are adjusting to
the new changes
and I encourage people to please as
we've been all along with every change
it takes time for these things to happen
so I encourage patience and kindness if
you're going into a long-term care home
or a health care facility in the next
few days
of course at any point and I can't
stress this enough anybody who is
showing symptoms of respiratory illness
you will be asked to wear masks you may
be asked to come at a different time of
the day so that you're not sitting in a
waiting room with other people
Etc
and of course we must continue to be
vigilant and take precautions and follow
our guidance that we know so well now uh
covet has not gone away we are still
seeing other viruses that cause
illnesses so importantly staying home or
away from others if you're feeling
unwell particular if you have a fever
that's a sign that you have something
that may be infectious to others and
really importantly don't go visit
elderly relatives or in long-term care
if you are feeling unwell practice the
respiratory etiquette that we've all
become used to so covering your mouth
when you cough using a tissue throwing
it away wearing a mask if you have mild
symptoms and you need to be out cleaning
your hands frequently still really
important
and remain our first lines of Defense
we are emerging from this pandemic and
we no longer need to have some of these
orders in place for masking for checking
vaccine stages but we need to continue
to be mindful and Vigilant and we will
be monitoring the trends of covid-19
influenza RSV and the other causes of
illness as well as the global situation
that we're in
this also means we may need to have an
additional dose of vaccine at some point
in the fall and those are things that we
don't yet know but we will be monitoring
and we'll be preparing for the fall
there may be mask requirements again in
certain settings as we head into
respiratory season next year
and I I want to emphasize as well that
the the one order that is still in place
and will remain in place is the the
requirement for healthcare workers in
all of our health care settings to be
vaccinated and that's incredibly
important everybody in our Healthcare
setting is vaccinated now and that
protects ourselves each other and the
settings that we work in and it's one of
the reasons why we have the confidence
in moving ahead with removing some of
the other restrictions in those settings
now
finally I want I'm very happy to let you
know that we actually have our third
round of the speak population Health
survey you recall we did two rounds and
over the last two years and we want to
hear from you about the impacts that the
pandemic and the measures that we've put
in place and where you are in this part
uh now in in this pandemic and this
helps us to understand where we need to
pay attention and to build resiliency
and well-being in our communities across
the problem Province so it will be
available very soon at the end of April
online in 10 languages and you can
register to participate using
bccdc.ca speak survey and I encourage
everybody to con to look for this when
it comes out in April and to provide
your feedback and your impact so that we
know what we can do to help support
people to recover over the next few
years so thank you very much
um I hope everybody has a very safe and
happy weekend and continues to remember
to be kind as we go through this next
phase of our pandemic thank you
uh thank you very much Dr Henry and
that's right you got the clicker it's
good
um so I want to talk a little bit about
hospitalization and where it stands and
you see in this chart the trajectory of
hospitalization Acute Care in BC from uh
January 6 when we met with the media and
uh and announced the opening of
Emergency Operations centers across
Health authorities and where we are
today and what you see is in that week
and this is what you see in front of you
is a seven day moving average tradition
typically on Monday There's fewer people
in the hospital than on Thursday so this
seven day moving average it shows where
that's been going we know that on
January 6th there were just over ten
thousand two hundred people uh in
hospital in BC and today they're 9
647 and you see what's happened in that
period which is
um the reduction somewhat of
hospitalizations but I want to put it in
context about how busy the Health Care
system is right now today in September
of 2020 the average hospitalization rate
was nine thousand four hundred you see
9400 well below the line on the chart
there that was the average in September
of 2020 not a period of high activity in
the Health Care System typically in the
month of September so this is a high
level and if you looked at the
hospitalization levels in 2020 and 2021
you'd see much lower levels than this
even though we were dealing at that time
of course with different phases of the
covid-19 pandemic what that tells us is
that hospitalization remains High and
the delivery of Health Care Services is
at a very high level in BC last week the
last measurable week we set another
record for that week for the number of
surgeries completed from a diagnostic
tests
completed but also there are healthcare
workers are are busy across the board
and so some of this reflects a decline
in respiratory illness season but what
mitigates against that is that there are
a lot of people who are who are needing
hospital care right now and are
sufficiently and seriously ill and
seriously ill enough and you have to be
seriously ill to be in hospital to get
hospital care I want to talk a little
bit about what happened in January 2023
we put in place the Emergency Operations
centers to prepare and manage for these
issues around Hospital occupancy a
number of actions were put in place
seven day a week support integration
with urgent and Primary Care Centers
implementing quick response teams we
added long-term care and Community beds
in the system
measures in the hundreds were taken
across Health authorities to address and
deal with the day-to-day challenges of
very high Hospital occupancy on March
13th we stood down the eocs with many of
the strategies they'll implemented
staying in place and we're continuing to
to implement actions that are focused on
reducing edmissions improving efficiency
reducing alternate level of care rates
which is very important in our hospital
system ensuring that patients are cared
for in the proper setting so that
process is as we said would be a time
limited process but the measures that we
put in place continue to be in place
going forward obviously we're going to
have to continued sustained focus on
Hospital capacity so you're going to see
in the late summer early fall Dr Henry
and I will be here to present as we
prepare for Respiratory illness season
next year but also looking at actions we
need to take in that period to
potentially add Hospital capacity to
ensure that patient flow efficiencies
are in place and uh and also
community-based strategies that we'll
see so we're going to learn the lessons
of this year and continue to work on
this we presented our acute care
strategies for the fall in advance of
the Fall 2020 2021 and of course 2022
you'll remember and so uh that process
you can expect to see later on this year
with respect to in particular long-term
care but also Acute Care Dr Henry uh
spoke of changes in provincial Health
orders today one of the actions that we
took during the pandemic it was a
commitment was made in September 2020
that we would add 7 000 people to our
health care System the majority of them
through a program called the healthcare
Access program which has been in terms
of health human resources one of the
most successful Health Human Resources
programs in North America in a long time
and you see the results of this you see
that as of March 31st
2023 that should say it reads slightly
wrong
1521 ftes that's that's full-time
equivalents full-time workers we're
working in long-term care and assisted
living and 577 FTE screeners were
working in acute care so those are on
the screening side people who are
working often the front doors many of
you will be familiar with that if you're
a visitor in long-term care implementing
the measures but also checking obviously
the vaccine requirements and so on as of
March 2023
5383 people been hired into the
healthcare access program
4388 of those in long-term care 910 and
home support 85 and acute care the
funding for those programs remains in
place and in fact the health care Access
program continues to expand
meaning that though some of the
requirements have been changing it's our
view that that staff continues to be
needed in those settings when we've made
it clear to both long-term care settings
and acute care settings at the funding
is placed and and well the work of some
of those that staff may change
especially on the screening side that
they'll be continuing to to work in
their respective uh facilities finally I
just wanted to talk a little bit about
um the immunization program in the fall
prefers for influenza
1.78 million British Columbians of doses
of influenza were administered in BC in
this flu year which is an absolute
record I believe the pass record was one
million five hundred and seventy five
thousand and this reflects I think and
comparative to other comparing to other
provinces this was an extraordinary
success I want to first of all thank
British Columbians for responding to it
you saw in the data presented by Dr
Henry he's a visible
um a visible demonstration of the effect
of that uh commitment by people to get
vaccinated I just note that
overwhelmingly those vaccinations were
delivered in pharmacies around BC in an
unprecedented way and that uh the result
of that in fact one million 226 000 of
them were delivered in pharmacies about
25 percent of their major 436 000 in uh
in health authority clinics and the rest
in in primary care provider offices the
remaining five percent this is of course
all-time records for the participation
of Pharmacists and it was pharmacists in
communities around BC who played I think
a critical and important role both in
the delivery of the covid-19 vaccine and
the delivery of the influenza vaccine
this had an effect on people people's
Health was spared because these actions
were taken and we are very appreciative
for everyone involved the uh with
respect to the spring booster campaign
Dr Henry talked about the need for
immunization for most people that may
come in the fall but for some there's a
program now those who are most
vulnerable uh and these were based on
the priority groups set out by Dr Henry
and by Nasi
um just to note that the long-term care
Assisted Living Program for the that
spring booster will commence Tuesday
April 11th and be complete by uh the end
of May
2023. in addition invites have been
going out in order to Priority groups
those over 80 those who are clinically
extremely vulnerable over 18 and groups
one and two that's about a hundred
thousand people the next priority will
people who are clinically vulnerable in
what's called category three that's
about 150 000 more people uh people uh
with 50 to 69 who are indigenous and uh
and 60 to 79 of the general population
and no history of covet so those are
priority groups that have been set out
and then it'll continue on with the
priority groups as set out by Dr Henry
in our previous briefings I just say
that last up to now about 14
650 doses have been administered in our
spring booster Campaign which has just
begun at the end of last week and
yesterday
noting that the invitations have been
going out 14 000 a coveted vaccination
bookings were completed
over 600 pharmacies and 75 health
authority clinics all over the province
have Books Spring booster appointments
and a small number of children for their
govid there's a number of children as
well who are obviously eligible another
16 health authority clinics are
available for them across the province
in short this effort this vaccine
campaign has reflected an exceptional
effort across public health and across
Community Pharmacy we are very
appreciative and I think everybody can
see the positive effects on health of a
successful immunization campaign as we
prepare for next year's effort it
demonstrates I think our continuing
capacity to deliver an import a response
to the covid-19 vaccine the covid-19
pandemic I I just wanted to to say to
everyone that the pandemic of course
continues and we have adapted again and
again but some of the fundamental
principles that we've learned together
in this time are important and we need
there they bear repeating stay home when
you're sick
the most important thing wash our hands
regularly cough into our sleeve all of
the things that we've learned have
helped us in dealing not just with
covid-19 but with other respiratory
illnesses I encourage everyone who has
done all of these things for for a very
long period of time in support of one
another in our health to continue to do
so to continue of course to learn and
follow Public Health uh public health
information about covid-19 as we
continue through this phase of the
pandemic and with that I'll invite Dr
Henry back and we'll be happy to take
your questions
a reminder to reporters on the line
please press star one for the
opportunity to ask a question and a
follow-up I will quickly look around the
room to see if we have questions from
the room to start we are going to start
with Kylie Stanton Global News uh Kylie
please go ahead sorry I can't see you
the lights are sorry uh Dr Henry you say
you were emerging from the pandemic do
you have a timeline or you know are we
through are we through it can you give a
give us an idea you know I think we've
been coming out of the emergency phase
for sure and I think today is a good
reflection of that that we you know some
of the additional restrictions we had in
place through this past respiratory
season have really helped us get through
that phase
um where we still see quite a lot of
covet and we saw that in our data today
we're seeing that around the world but I
think in the next few months we're
likely to to be able to say we're no
longer in a pandemic covet is going to
be with us and we're going to have to be
prepared for the uncertainty of next
year I talked about this a bit in the
fall you know that we're going to see
oscillations that change and we're sort
of in a bit more of a steady state now
but we still don't know yet about the
periodicity or the seasonality of this
virus we have some ideas that it's worse
in the winter when other things are
worse and a little bit easier in the
summer and we're sort of seeing that but
we'll have to watch that so I I think
the that we're in that middle phase I
think the emergency the the Declaration
of a pandemic is likely to be over in
the next couple of months and then we'll
just need to be prepared for next winter
season when we're likely to see again
some combination of influenza and RSV
and and covid and so what does that mean
for booster shots
um going into the fall will everyone
need them or um will it just be for
priority groups yeah that's a very good
question to which I have no answer no I
can tell you my speculation so what
we're seeing and uh is that uh that
combination of having had your primary
series which is for the most part two
doses plus uh additional boosters and
those boosters and the bivalent boosters
are making a difference for people and
we do see some waning of immunity from
um from vaccine alone or from infection
alone but now as a the zero prevalence
shows us and and we're seeing this
globally as well that that hybrid
immunity seems to be long lasting
particularly to protect people against
more severe illness causing
hospitalizations or leading to need for
critical care Etc and that um as we're
monitoring it over time seems to be
pretty steady so it is light and that's
why this you know the who came out with
very similar recommendations about this
spring only higher risk people who don't
get as strong a response from vaccine I
really need the vaccine right now going
into the fall I suspect we'll have a
program similar to what we do with
influenza where it will be available for
Everyone by that point most of us will
be at least a year since our last
booster dose and so we we will likely
see some waning or decreasing of
immunity so it's likely and this is you
know my speculation right now given what
we've been watching around the world
that will have a program where everybody
is it's available for everybody but
we'll focus again on those people who
are at highest risk of hospitalization
severe illness with both covet and
influenza and I'm hopeful that in the
future there's a lot of great research
that's been done on vaccines right now
that we're going to have a combination
vaccine either combination of influenza
Plus covid or hopefully a vaccine that's
what we call a pan coronavirus vaccine
that may only need to be given maybe in
two doses and that will protect us
against all the different variants of of
coronavirus so there's lots of really
exciting things that we don't yet have
answers for
our next question comes from Katie
DeRosa Vancouver's son hi Dr Henry if
you're eliminating the requirement for
vaccination for visitors will there be
any decision on the vaccination status
for for health care workers yeah so
we've been talking about that and I I
think I was very clear but no right now
the requirement to be vaccinated to work
on a Health Care system is incredibly
important it has what has allowed us to
um to now get back to a more normal
pre-pandemic Health Care system in our
long-term care homes in our hospitals so
that requirement and we now have a
hundred percent of people in our health
care System pretty much who are
vaccinated and that's been so important
it protects us it protects us from
passing it on to each other protects us
from having more severe illness so that
we're unable to work and it protects us
from
um and protects the people that we care
for so that is an ongoing requirement
it's a really important one as I said we
still have a lot of uncertainty over the
next little while but I don't see that
lifting and this may be for you or for
Minister Dix it's about the nursed
patient ratios and will it apply to
private long-term care settings and if
so how do you enforce private long-term
care to have the required number of
nurses
too
so uh two sets of things there are at
the distinguish between settings here
there's acute care hospital those are
all public in BC
in long-term care there are about 30 000
publicly funded long-term care bets in
the province
about 30 to 32 percent of those are held
30 owned and operated the other is 68
percent there might be not for profit
they might be for-profit but they're all
publicly funded beds that's how we
deliver the service in BC so when you're
applying these standards you do it
across across that system right and so
these are contractual this is uh a
commitment that was made not uh in a
contractual negotiation but with the BC
nurses Union so it will apply across the
Public Health Care System but that
Public Health Care System we understand
um is means a lot of places where the
delivery isn't health authority owned
delivery that can be doctors offices of
course that can be
long-term care homes that that have
public beds so that's where the system
has been placed that's what we've agreed
to and that's what we're working towards
but my expectation would be that when
you as you raise standards for nursing
is that that raising of standards would
have an effect on the very small part of
the system which would be a fully
private Care Home of some sort but this
is for the public system for public
hospital for public long-term care for
public Community Care
um and sometimes that public care is
delivered as I say by a care home is
owned by a private operator
next question Mary Brook Island social
trends hi thank you
um so the obvious earmarks of the
pandemic seem to have faded people
aren't wearing masks in public they're
back to handshaking instead of the elbow
bump that was recommended at one point
and so I'm just wondering if you'll be
making strong recommendations to the
public Community like to businesses
schools
retail in particular so that they
maintain their Plexiglas perhaps in some
situations or ventilation on thinking in
particular a lot of spaces have not been
altered whatsoever so now that the masks
are down the risk frankly is up in some
closed tight retail spaces yeah so I
think we we are in a different place now
and we look at the the zero prevalence
that tells us the level of protection we
have in our community so these things
that we put in place when uh there
wasn't vaccination there wasn't immunity
we no longer need to have them in every
situation but that doesn't mean that
everybody is still uh has the same
degree of risk there are some people who
have compromised immune systems for
example who may not respond as well to
vaccines older people where it wanes
more quickly and you may want to
continue to wear a well-fitted
respirator or Mass to protect yourself
if you're going into those situations
but we can go back to having a more
normal interaction in many of the
situations we're in now because we're
not at that same risk level anymore and
while I for one hope to never go back to
shaking hands just because for my own
reasons I prefer the fist bump but you
know these are things that uh that some
people feel very strongly about and it's
important gestures for them so I think
we can go back safely now to many of
these uh many of these rituals and
ceremonies that we had been putting off
for this last little while we've learned
so much about how connectedness is so
important for our emotional and mental
health as well as our physical health so
I don't think we need to continue to
have barriers in many of these
situations we absolutely need to
continue to pay attention to indoor air
quality and ventilation and we've
learned something about that and so we
need to continue and I know we've been
working with the schools for example to
make sure there's assessments and
upgrading of ventilation systems in
every school in the province
but the other really key things that we
have in our control now as we get back
to more normal
interactions in many different settings
is staying away if we're not feeling
well ourselves or if we just have a mild
symptom to wear a mask and you know I do
that to stay home particularly if you
have a fever to not go visit somebody
who's more at risk if you're not feeling
well yourself so those are the things
that we used to do maybe not thinking
about it we often have this idea of
presenteeism that we had to go to work
no matter how bad we are feeling I hope
we have learned that now we can make it
okay for somebody not to come for Easter
dinner or Passover dinner if they're not
feeling well themselves and that we're
more
aware of these issues and more
um what's the right word I'm trying to
find is uh more patient with each other
about these issues and so if you're
somebody in a very crowded environment
wear a mask or even keep your distance
from people if and particularly stay
away from people who are more at risk if
you're not feeling well
now that we have long covered with us
for some people
um I'm just wondering will that remain
between a doctor and their patient to
determine whether they have that and
will those people still have access to
clinics and will there be in the um line
item somewhere in that BC Health budget
that will continue the attention to Long
covet and make sure that there are
facilities within hospitals or that
studies will continue that it will be
paid attention to going forward
absolutely yeah so I know the minister
will have something about that but you
know we're learning as we go with this
so there's post covet syndromes that for
some people are very debilitating and
for some people last quite a long time
and we have a series of clinics they are
now mostly virtual and they are able to
provide the assessment and care that
people need and support people's Primary
Care Providers to support them as well
so globally we are learning about the
different types of of long coveted
syndromes that are out there and how
they can be best managed the the things
that we are also learning is that
vaccinations make a big difference in
preventing Lancome even if you do get
sick and that we're seeing less of it in
the last year with with Omicron that
doesn't mean that that we're out of the
woods there's clearly things that we
need to follow
um and that you know the the positive
side is we are seeing that most people
get better over time and they need to be
supported over time so absolutely we'll
be continuing
um to support people getting the tests
they need getting the access to the the
support from the the um the Clinics of
which we have access around the province
now that they're virtual as well and I
know Minister Dix can talk about funding
um and specif specifically on the
funding the the funding is there and
those the Clint the funding for that
network has been made permanent what
changed in a really a short period of
time from the fall of 2022 to the early
months of 2023 was the number of people
presenting uh to those clinics across
the province and there are only a few
locations against obviously uh cases
that came around from across across the
problem so we went in a given month from
about 750 referrals to about 80
referrals and that changes the way you
organizing your health care response we
were the first Province to put in a
network of care around what some what's
called long covet it's called different
things it's called long covet that is
continue to be there it's now funded in
the base of the the Health Care System
it's organized uh centrally and that
allows us to provide care everywhere in
the province and so there was some
discussion around the existence of the
clinics and whether the systems should
stay the same it obviously doesn't say
stay the same when the number of um of
new referrals drops by approximately 90
percent you want to adjust but the care
is there and there's Continuing Care
being provided to thousands of British
Columbians through that network but for
any system of chronic treatment to be
effective it has to be effective
everywhere and it has to be based on a
strong Primary Care system and a strong
team-based care across the province
supported by that network of expertise
we're learning more every single day and
Dr Henry will tell you many much about
what we're learning about the ongoing
impact of um of covid-19 on on some
people who are dealing with that and so
we want the best evidence and the best
possible information available that is
at the core of what we do now and it's
been become a permanent item in the
healthcare budget
one more question in the room before we
go to the phones we hear from Mira Bain
CBC okay this question is for Dr Henry
um my colleagues are wondering if you
could expand upon you know what kind of
healthcare settings might we see the
universal mandatory masking lifted in
are we talking about hospitals clinics
or what kind of situations so right now
there's a combination of ministerial
orders and public health officer orders
that require all visitors all staff to
wear masks at all times in healthcare
settings and there's recommendations to
uh Community providers through the
colleges to around masking in in
Physicians offices for for example so
today all of those orders are lifted so
there is no more mandatory Universal
masking in all Healthcare settings so in
hospitals in long-term care homes
however there are many situations in
healthcare where masks are used
routinely and we do what we call a point
of care risk assessment so if there's a
patient who has certain types of droplet
spread diseases and then they're in a
certain room and one of the precautions
that healthcare workers do is wear masks
and in outbreaks for example of
respiratory illness Mass are part of
what we do to help manage those
outbreaks along with other things
including visitor restrictions Etc so
what we're taking away is the mandatory
all the time for everybody in the
healthcare setting because we no longer
need that extra level of protection
having said that we're talking with the
infection prevention and control and
occupational health experts both across
Canada and in BC and you know that we
recognize that in healthcare settings
particularly wearing of mass was very
helpful when we had a lot of respiratory
illness around so we'll be looking at
that again for next fall
uh and this question is for Minister Dix
um this is uh from one of my other
colleagues
um and this is about the Kamloops
maternity Clinic uh what's being done to
ensure expectant parents in the Kamloops
area will have access to care once the
Region's largest maternity clinic closes
this summer due to Staffing shortages so
we've been working very closely with uh
the doctors and others working in
maternity and Kamloops and uh we were
very positive that there will be a
solution to that worked out uh in
advance of the closure you're talking
about
Long-Term Care Homes the residence
service Assisted Living Elizabeth
obligatory
okay we'll go to the phones now we'll
hear first from Bender Sachin CTV Bender
please go ahead
hi there I'm just wondering um in the
last couple of weeks I feel like I've
heard and this is anecdotal of course
more people Contracting uh covid-19 and
I'm just wondering
um you know I think hospitalizations may
have shown that as well but just
wondering like you know if you can talk
a little bit about that and why you
think now is the right time to be
lifting these mandates yeah so we look
at this in many different ways and some
of which I presented today so yeah lots
of people are still getting sick
um and some people with covid but we're
not seeing an increase in
hospitalizations from covid and we're
not seeing uh increases in critical care
and people getting very sick with covet
and um as we were showing the other
respiratory illnesses that cause a lot
of uh of sickness this time of year have
come down dramatically so prior to this
pandemic it is around this time of year
that we would have the end of of the
respiratory season and and we're seeing
that again this year that it is at a
place where it's manageable it's not
causing uh overwhelming the Health Care
System but it's not gone away and the
data shows that you know covet is
definitely out there but so our
adenoviruses and enteroviruses and other
things that cause uh respiratory
illnesses and so we always have to be
aware of that and if we are sick
ourselves with one of these to stay away
from others so we're not passing it on
to take all those measures that we know
can make a difference
follow-upender
no I'm good thank you thanks very much
we have time for one more question today
we go to Alexandra Igan the logic
Alexandra please go ahead
hi thanks so much for the minister I I'm
wondering you know today we got
confirmation that goes on Telehealth and
Harrison Healthcare are in discussions
with the MSC and the ministry on the
injunctions that were filed against them
a couple months ago and I'm wondering
what has changed to have the government
decide to engage on this outside the
court system and if you can shed any
light on where that process is at today
um nothing's changed the Medicare
protection act applies in British
Columbia it will continue to apply uh
frequently the Medical Services
Commission intervenes when uh violations
occur or or there's concern about
whether they've occurred and worked that
out with the provider to ensure that
patients are protected in the case of
the two Health Care Services you're
talking about a small portion of the
Telus service and Harrison
Health the action was taken injunctive
action was taken and those matters are
before the courts Medical Services
Commission has taken action it's normal
in such proceeding that there might be
discussion and those of you who are
watching the proceedings know that there
have been some adjournment but
just to be clear the Medicare protection
act applies patients will be protected
against their extra billing in BC we
brought in measures in 2018
regulations that had not been brought
into forced to do that and that's what's
occurring but of course this is what the
the Medicare Services Commission the
Medical Services Commission under the
outstanding direction of Dr Halton he
does frequently and so it shouldn't be a
surprise but it's not a change what's
what it hasn't changed Is our commitment
to enforce the Medicare protection act
and to protect British Columbians
against extra billing
follow up Alex
yeah just um in a similar famous Supreme
Court of Canada decision on Candy
surgeries today
appeal what what happens to the clinic
now uh will it be shut down will it say
signs going forward will there be
retroactive signs to sort of what
happens to that clinic now well the law
applies remember you have to understand
what the court case was the court case
was can be Surgical and it received
enormous breathtaking uh fundraising
from its supporters to bring the case
over a very significant period of time
they brought a lawsuit against uh the
government it wasn't the other way
around in that case it's different than
the injunctions we're talking about in
the other matter and so the decision by
the Supreme Court ends the matter and I
just want to say it is an exceptional
um victory for public health care in BC
for the people of BC for the Medicare
protection act for our Public Health
Care System it supports Public Health
Care and has us do what we need to do
which to provide continuingly better
service under public like under the
Public Health Care system and that's
exactly what we're going to do I want to
acknowledge the exceptional work by
Jonathan Penner all of the all the
lawyers who worked on this in-house
lawyers who worked on this at the
ministry of the Attorney General who did
I think on behalf of the people of BC an
exceptional and Brilliant job in
defending Public Health Care in the
courts but that issue is not a matter
brought by the government of BC it was a
matter brought against the government BC
obviously at the trial stage we had the
our position was upheld the government
BC effectively won at that stage and now
the Supreme Court is not going forward
or not provided leave for appeal so the
matter is closed and unless I think you
can probably tell I'm delighted
to everyone that concludes today's event